Traductor: Luz Alejandra Magre Colorado
Revisor: Carmen de Miguel-Murado
Se puede mejorar la vida de una ciudad.
Mucha gente no cree esto.
He encontrado durante mi vida
muchos intendentes, gobernadores
que siempre afirman: "Mi ciudad
es muy grande, no es posible,
en mi ciudad no
tenemos los recursos".
Yo les digo: Les quiero compartir esto:
después de casi 40 años trabajando
en las ciudades, creo que una ciudad
puede mejorar su calidad de vida
significativamente en menos de 3 años.
Sí se puede.
Pero es necesario, claro, voluntad
política, solidaridad, estrategia.
Pero lo más importante, encontrar una
buena ecuación de co-responsabilidad.
Bueno, quiero empezar con algunos
personajes de un libro que escribí
hace 20 años tratando de enseñar
la ciudad a los niños adolescentes
y gente de todas las edades.
El mejor ejemplo de calidad
de vida para mí, es la tortuga,
porque la tortuga es vivir,
trabajar y moverse juntos.
Al mismo tiempo, el casco de la tortuga
tiene el diseño de una tesitura urbana.
¿Qué puede ocurrir si cortáramos
el casco de la tortuga?
Vivir aquí, trabajar ahí, el ocio ahí.
La tortuga se va a morir.
Es exactamente lo que estamos
haciendo con nuestras ciudades.
Vivir aquí, trabajar, guetos de gente
muy rica, guetos de gente muy pobre.
Estamos matando a la ciudad.
Y además, la ciudad es un organismo,
cuanto más se mezcla ingresos, edades,
funciones, más humana la ciudad se queda.
El otro personaje de este libro es Otto,
el automóvil, es un tipo muy egoísta,
que viene a fiesta y no quiere salir,
y bebe mucho y tose mucho,
y es muy egoísta, porque solo
transporta una, dos o tres personas.
Digo últimamente que el coche
es como nuestra suegra mecánica,
tenemos que tener buenas relaciones
con nuestras suegras,
Pero no podemos dejar que
ellas comanden nuestras vidas.
En otras palabras, si la única
mujer de tu vida es tu suegra,
tú tienes un problema.
(Risas)
Para mí, el tipo más
solidario es el Bandoneón,
es el bus amigo que
transporta 300 personas.
Las normas suecas dicen
270 suecos, 300 brasileños.
(Risas)
Cada ciudad tiene un diseño.
Si es lineal, radial, Curitiba, Río,
Oaxaca, San Francisco, California.
La ciudad es una estructura
de vida y trabajo juntos.
Toda vez que separamos vida
de trabajo, ocurre el desastre.
Eso no es solamente la ciudad,
es un estado en un país.
Tratar a la economía sin
las personas es el desastre.
Aquí está la estructura
de vida y trabajo de Curitiba.
Voy a pasar muy rápidamente.
Es una estructura de vida y trabajo
y transporte todos juntos,
y aquí hay más densidad donde hay
más oferta de transporte público,
aquí los buses de carril exclusivo,
ya lo conocen.
Hay tres problemas que son muy importantes
en todas las ciudades del mundo.
Sí educación, Sí salud, Sí la seguridad,
Sí la atención al niño,
pero hay tres puntos que
empiezan a ser fundamentales,
no solamente para vuestras ciudades
como para toda la humanidad.
Un problema es la movilidad,
el otro es la sostenibilidad,
y el tercero, la sociodiversidad.
La movilidad se puede hacer,
la gente espera a veces
un sistema que es muy caro
y se espera mucho.
Nosotros empezamos
de una manera muy sencilla:
un bus corriendo en carril exclusivo.
Empezamos con 25 000 pasajeros por día.
Hoy el sistema transporta
2 300 000 pasajeros al día.
Es igual al número de pasajeros
del metro de Sao Paulo
y más que el metro de Río
junto con el tren de suburbio.
Pero ¿en qué consiste?
Es un pequeño tubo que
transforma el bus en un metro,
que da al bus la misma
performance de un metro,
y se embarca, se paga antes,
se embarca al mismo nivel,
y no se espera más que
un minuto por el bus.
Y así es, sin vidrio, así es
como opera en mi ciudad.
Pocos metros en el mundo tienen
la posibilidad de dar la movilidad
a gente portadora de deficiencia.
Pero esto fue un ejemplo de hoy.
Aunque yo acredite que
el futuro está en la superficie,
yo creo que hoy está en
utilizar todos los sistemas.
Y si hay un metro que sea inteligente,
si hay un bus que sea inteligente,
un taxi inteligente,
una bicicleta inteligente,
un coche inteligente,
y el secreto de la movilidad está
en jamás disputar el mismo espacio,
o sea, ser complementario.
Y aquí los franceses transformaron
la bicicleta en un transporte público.
Y aquí es el coche, menor coche
del mundo que estoy dibujando, ahora.
Estamos en el cuarto prototipo,
no soy un diseñador de coches,
pero el concepto de un coche
que no tiene dueño,
es un coche "dockado",
"docking car".
Es dock-dock, es un cuarto
del tamaño del Smart.
Y yo entro dentro del coche.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Es dock-dock. Docado.
Y aquí está cómo funciona.
Dock, dock, dock, dock.
Ahora, este es el sistema que estamos
dibujando para la olimpiada en Río.
Y aquí (vemos) cómo se hace
la integración del bus con el metro.
El sistema es el mismo,
solo el vehículo es diferente.
Pero puede imaginar el vídrio
con el paisaje de Río de Janeiro.
Bueno, la otra cosa: ¿es posible
tener una ciudad sin periferia?
Sí, es posible.
Aquí hay un estudio que hicimos
para el futuro de Sao Paulo,
donde tomamos el trazado del ferrocarril
y dibujamos una "promenade"
arriba del trazado
para que se conecten
todos los tipos de ingresos.
El área es equivalente a dos veces
el Central Park en New York,
y la gente se puede conectar e ir
en bicicleta, caminar por toda la ciudad,
toda la gente tendría acceso
a transporte público
porque el tren de suburbio está abajo,
y aquí se puede conectar
todo tipo de vivienda.
Bueno, qué es una ciudad sostenible?
He participado en muchas reuniones,
mucha gente piensa:
Bueno, la sostenibilidad es
nuevos materiales. Muy importante.
Es nuevas formas de energía.
Muy importante.
Es, digamos, reciclaje,
es edificios verdes.
Todo eso muy importante,
pero hay que pensar.
Lo más importante es que 75 %
de las emisiones de carbono
se originan en las ciudades.
O sea, es en la ciudad donde
podemos ser más efectivos.
¿Cómo?
Utilizando menos el coche,
separando la basura
y viviendo más cerca del trabajo.
Recién completamos una película
que trata de enseñar a los niños,
cómo tornar su ciudad más sostenible.
Y aquí como se cambió
de medio metro cuadrado
para 52 metros cuadrados
por habitante en Curitiba,
cómo se transformó las canteras en sitios.
La universidad Libre de Medio Ambiente,
Jardín botánico,
aquí una cantera se transformó
en un teatro en dos meses,
hay que ser rápido, y hay
varias razones para ser rápido.
Una, para evitar nuestra
propia burocracia;
dos, una vez la decisión política
está tomada, hay que empezar.
Y tercero, es que a veces
tenemos muy buenas ideas
y pensamos: Esto no es posible,
es mi idea, quizás no sea posible.
Hay que empezar porque innovar es empezar.
Podemos escribir un tratado de cómo nadar,
movimientos de los brazos al mismo tiempo,
pero en el momento que tú
te sumerges en el agua ¡uf, era tan fácil!
Yo recuerdo cuando era joven,
y muy joven, y leía tratados sobre sexo,
y después me di cuenta que era
solo iniciar, que no era tan difícil.
Aquí canteras que fueron transformadas.
Aquí cómo se da el cambio en la basura.
Hicimos esas campañas empezando
por los niños. Eso es importante.
Durante seis meses enseñamos a esos niños
y los niños enseñaron a sus padres.
Y hay el 70 % de la gente en Curitiba
que separa la basura en su casa.
Y bueno, identidad y cómo se transforma,
y cómo sé yo muy rápidamente este cambio
creando sitios que respeten
nuestra identidad.
Parque ucraniano, el parque polaco,
el parque japonés, el parque alemán,
e inmediatamente después,
la unión soviética se dispersó
y tenían como tenemos gente de
Kazajistán, Turkmenistán, Uzbekistán,
tuvimos que parar el programa.
Bueno, yo les quiero decir
que es importante entender
que una ciudad se puede
cambiar inmediatamente.
Eso es lo que yo llamo acupuntura,
o sea, se puede crear una nueva
energía con algunas acciones focales
que pueden dar una nueva
energía a la ciudad.
Y aquí ejemplos de acupunturas
magníficas, simples.
El menor parque de Nueva York,
13 x 32, es el más bonito.
El Museo Oscar Niemeyer en Curitiba.
Aquí estamos haciendo el pabellón
de la Bossa Nova en Río.
Aquí, el museo de la movilidad,
el museo de la sostenibilidad,
y aquí una acupuntura que propusimos
para Buenos Aires, la Bombonera.
Cómo decir, era Macri el presidente,
después asumió la intendencia
y el nuevo presidente no quiso hacerlo.
Pero para mí, sigue siendo la Bombonera.
Sao Paulo y las calles portátiles.
Cómo traer vida, cómo planear
el aglomerado urbano de Brasilia,
y traer vida a sitios
que están decadentes.
Y aquí un parque donde, de manera
muy sencilla, con bouquets de bambú,
se crea una plaza de sombra.
No hay que gastar muchos recursos
como hicieron en Valencia
haciendo un umbraculum que es una
maravilla, es un genio, pero cuesta caro.
Y aquí, una serie de acupunturas que
estamos haciendo en todo el mundo.
Como salvar un río en
República Dominicana.
Bueno, para aquí como ocupar
una isla en Mazatlán, México.
Cómo recuperar el perfil de un morro.
Aquí la calle portátil, que estamos
desarrollando, y ahí está.
Y el hombre tortuga, que soy yo,
que carga la casa en la espalda.
Para cerrar, les voy a invitar a cantar
conmigo el "Tango de la sostenibilidad".
Uds. hagan el ritmo
porque son Uds. que saben.
(Ritmo de tango)
Bandoneón, bandoneón,
bandoneón, bandoneón.
Usa menos tu coche.
Siga siempre el bandoneón.
Bandoneón, bandoneón, bandoneón.
Separa tu basura, en tu propia habitación.
Bandoneón, bandoneón.
Viva cerca del trabajo,
siga siempre este guión.
Bandoneón.
¡Sí se puede, macanudo!
Gracias.
(Aplausos)